mais bien on va être la lumière on va
faire l'interview dernier coup à sa
bougie ainsi ouais j'ai un peu bouge à
la journée sont vaincus latter truc
quand je suis à votre avis sur ces
valeurs que vous êtes prêts le dernier
coup à vous dernier coup dur
bordeaux s'est passé à rihanna le truc
adriana can you please translate for the
girl traduire traduit très bien elle est
toujours là pouf dans les coups de tête
dernier en voiture le pardon ma dernière
voiture c'est quoi moi je veux faire la
pub je les payais quand même j'ai quand
même pas mal que gratuite frigo
peinture connaissez seule seconde une
berline un peu confortable à c'est un
beau char bon recharge bien mes coups de
coeur ce qui critique la neige est un
qui dit qu'il me relis tes de seattle
d'ailleurs roger beauvais josé gauche
djouzi oui bon dernier coup de coeur
alors dernier coup de coeur qui me
réussit pas mal
vous allez vous marier peut-être c'est
sa gonzesse de kimberley une seattle
déçu
ben écoute bluff kimberley non violente
en découdra elle est partie quelques
semaines quelques semaines et là tu es
un petit peu à cran puisque une bombe a
alors avis aux amatrices
il est chaud le garçon rallume bien